[Music]
foreign
welcome back to dope Tech in techtember
the busiest most wonderful time of the
year but I've got three really cool
things to show you so first up is this
laptop here this is the Dell XPS 13 plus
uh it's probably the hottest laptop
design I have ever seen and then when
you actually get to using the laptop you
pretty quickly realize it's a little bit
more difficult to use specifically
because of the sick design it's like
probably the purest example of form over
function I've ever seen let me explain
so just look at this thing look at this
thing most laptops look really similar
to each other but when I picture it like
a modern even slightly futuristic laptop
this is what comes to mind it's this all
white clean thin folding piece of metal
with edge to edge everything basically
the keyboard goes to edge to edge but is
also particularly flat without being
terrible to type on which looks really
good and it matches up with this 13 inch
4K OLED touch screen also going corner
to corner and this is not the only
laptop to have basically full screen
display corner to corner but the fact
that it does it all while keeping the
webcam up at the top and not having a
notch is welcomed and then down below
the keyboard you have this track pad but
it's an invisible track pad you might
have been looking at this laptop
wondering like why does it look so clean
this is definitely why it's a it's still
a normal sized normal shaped track pad
under here but it's an area underneath
this single piece of glass that doesn't
move at all it just vibrates with the
haptics to simulate the feel of a click
and it's quite good at it and then all
of that put together in this clean metal
body with metallic chamfered edges the
half inch total thickness it's under
three pounds makes it a pretty sweet
aesthetic for an everyday laptop however
uh you all know what form over function
means so as hot as this laptop is there
are some pretty clear trade-offs that
make it obvious why others aren't
running to copy everything that they did
here so like the trackpad for example is
super good looking but as you can
imagine when your finger leaves the
sensitive surface area the mouse just
stops working you just kind of have to
get used to knowing where it ends so
there's a reason why other laptop
manufacturers even though they also use
one piece track pads that don't move
they will clearly Define the trackpad
area visually and then the keyboard it's
a quirky one you know you've got the
power button cutting into the backspace
button a little bit up on the right side
here there's the shorter up and down
arrow keys I guess for the most part
even though it's flat and the keys
aren't particularly clicky this is a
reasonable keyboard until you get to the
touch bar right above it so we've seen
touch bars before and there's a reason
why we've kind of just started moving
back away from them this one is
definitely not any better than the rest
it's a soft Escape key and then F1
through F12 and then they can turn it
into media controls and quick controls
As you move around between apps but this
is an even worse version of a touch bar
because it's not a screen so you don't
really have visual confirmation of your
touch targets and they're smaller than
normal touch targets and there's no
haptic feedback it's just not fun to use
and then also you know yes this is a
beautiful thin crafted piece of metal
which is awesome to see in an everyday
laptop but you might have noticed
there's only one two USBC ports and no
headphone jack on this entire laptop
which is not nice to see on an everyday
laptop actually here's the perfect
example of form over function with this
laptop it's super clean and and nice
looking right there's no like indent for
your thumb where you'd normally be able
to open the laptop because I guess they
wanted it to look
super nice and sharp at the bottom which
it does but now this is not as easy to
yeah form over function either way I
still consider this dope Tech just
because it is still a pretty respectable
laptop inside decent specs and
everything there's also a high refresh
rate display option I'll link to a full
dave2d review where he goes over a lot
more of this stuff in depth benchmarks
Etc but for now I guess I just leave
this with a better understanding of why
more laptops don't look just like this
one all right so the next piece of dope
Tech is something we've had for a little
while now it's actually a piece of gear
that we've been using behind the scenes
on a couple of these more recent videos
and it's also from the sponsor of this
video it's an Eco flow so you might have
been watching the ionic 5 review and
been thinking wow this is the best ionic
5 review ever made how do they shoot
that so long story a lot of fun gear a
lot of practice goes into stuff like
that but one of the most underrated
Parts behind the whole thing was a
mobile Power Station powering it all so
that was ecoflow's Delta Pro which is an
absolute loot tank this thing was
powering the camera the audio device the
light we used just everything we used
with way more than enough extra to
charge up anyone's laptops or
smartphones or any other gadgets and yes
before we start typing some of you are
eagle-eyed enough to realize that the
rivian we're shooting with also has some
power ports but then how are we supposed
to get this shot with the rivian in the
background hundreds of feet away that
would be the Delta Pro now as we've also
probably been able to guess by the fact
that I'm outside again yes this whole
video shoot is powered by a Delta Pro
but they also have a smaller slightly
more affordable more portable version
this is called the Delta II it's still
ridiculously capable this here is a one
kilowatt hour battery but it's got an
expansion Port here because you can
connect it to more and daisy chain them
together and have up to three kilowatt
hours just to these and just one of
these can power up to 15 devices
simultaneously you can see these six AC
outlets on the back just these by
themselves can do 1800 watts of study
output and then around the front there's
some usba and some USBC ports that'll do
100 watts and then there's a screen that
breaks down how much power you're
outputting and how much time it'll last
but even better than the screen they
also have a smartphone app that connects
via Bluetooth that just breaks down
exactly how much power each Port is
drawing the temperatures the time
remaining and even this real-time graph
which is sick when we finally do run
through this whole thing it can fast
charge up back from zero to eighty
percent in like 50 minutes and I think
you can go to 100 in under an hour and a
half but it's good for 3 000 charge
cycles like that which is like a decade
if you used it a whole thing every
single day it's great these are the same
types of batteries that are in Tesla's
Vehicles very durable there's also a
five year warranty that covers
everything it's one of those pieces of
gear that you don't realize how
important it is to you until it's
pointed out to you like a favorite lens
or something so the bigger Delta Pro
Power Station this guy is 3.6 kilowatt
hours and can sustain 3 600 watts of AC
output which is crazy and that one can
even be linked up to your home as a
battery backup and it can be charged up
via solar panels or even at a level 2
electric car charging station with
included accessories it can also be
charged up via multiple sources at once
that's incredible this thing is a real
beast but here's the kicker and this is
a question I get like all the time about
electric cars so when you drive a gas
car and you run out of gas you can
always have someone go find a nearest
gas station but grab a bunch of gasoline
and like a pitcher or a can bring it to
you and fill it up what happens if you
run out of electricity in a
battery-powered car
well now the answer is
you get a battery and someone can bring
you an actual battery one of these
ecoflow Pros even and it'll just plug
right in and actually charge up the car
straight from the outlet on the side and
it is super impressive it is it's not
going to be the fastest charge in the
world but you can see it's drawing
nearly a thousand Watts you can add one
or two miles real quick just to get to
the nearest fast charger and that is
incredibly useful it's kind of thing
where I feel like every roadside
assistance vehicle should just have one
of these now because of how popular
electric cars are getting and that would
help a lot of people out so yeah anyway
if you want to get one of these it's
great for our portable Studio use but
it's great for peace of mind too if you
want to grab the two or the pro you can
use the promo code I have down below
which is MKBHD ef8 that'll get you eight
percent off your order so you're welcome
all right so a few days ago I got an
email asking if I wanted to try haptic
gloves in VR and I got a lot of weird
emails so I was very close to just
skipping over this one but something
made me say yes to this one I'm very
glad I said yes so this is a fascinating
piece of tech and the idea is pretty
simple it's not a finished product by
any means but the concept is what if you
could feel
inside of VR like VR the visuals are
getting so much better it's entertaining
your sense of hearing now too it's
getting more and more immersive but
here's one more of your senses to
actually entertain like feeling stuff
inside of the virtual reality world now
the major VR headsets that are out right
now don't really do this so this is like
a sort of a hack or a layer built on top
of that so for the Quest 2 that I've
been using for a while you have the
gloves and then the gloves attach to the
actual controller itself so you end up
looking like you have a rig basically
like this as you use it in the game
which is kind of a lot but they've built
some experiences inside of the VR world
to actually take advantage of these
gloves and they're pretty impressive
before we can start assembling the robot
we need to clean up the place place the
drink cans inside the trash bin
you can like kind of hear the haptic
engine or motor working
but I'm picking up a can I can feel that
throwing it out you can see like one
finger at a time move exactly the way
you tell it to
put my thumb in close it open it
it's pretty sick pick up the left wheel
and snap it to the robot unfortunately
there's no weight of anything like when
something is heavy like this should be a
really heavy object
I don't know how they would add weight
to it but that would be kind of cool
all right this is the part where you get
to feel the trigger of the drill
pick up the drill and jump off the arms
and the wheels of the robot with the
drill this is a complete experience I
feel the drill vibrating when I squeeze
the trigger and it's only my pointer
finger that feels resistance when I
squeeze the trigger of the drill
that is good
so there are wires down each of the
fingers as you can see and they're
connected to Motors in the knuckles that
can give you up to 20 newtons of
resistance per finger then there's
vibration Motors in the thumb and the
tips of all the fingers and in the Palm
so the idea is anytime you grab
something or touch something or hit or
squeeze something or let go of something
all of that is slightly more feelable
you can feel all of that when wearing
the gloves instead of holding a
controller
you know really the most interesting
thing to me is that all of this is on
the outside of the finger so it can only
do a certain type of force like
squeezing you can really feel but you
don't actually feel the object in your
hands it would be cool if this was
developed more and I think that's what's
going to happen I think you're going to
start to see the other VR headset makers
actually work on this problem because
they also are thinking about immersion
and then I think the future of this is
endless like imagine I imagine a lot of
sports games like driving games feeling
the resistance of the wheel while you're
in VR or even something like I don't
know you're holding a tennis racket or a
ping pong imagine ping pong while
feeling the spin you can put on the ball
it's crazy that's going to be super
Advanced anyway as of right now the
company that's making these sense gloves
is selling them in super limited
quantities to Enterprise companies for 4
500 euros a pop so companies like
Volkswagen and the European Space Agency
have sets of these for procedure visual
training which is still pretty cool but
again I'm really glad I said yes to this
experience because this is this is dope
Tech this is the bleeding edge of stuff
that makes sense mentally now but is
going to be really cool sometime in the
future and I can't wait for that
either way
that's been it thanks for watching
catch you guys in the next one
[Music]